>> LEAD
REPUIC KA
MURCFAYS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BEHAVIORN
DIFFICULT TO VERYOT HIS
RE-ELECTION.
REMEMBERRAISINGSP FTER
SAORMER TRUM
CRITICITHR-IN-CS
ROIF'
CHAIR ADMIRAL MAKE  IF MR. TRU
BEING
ALSUND
1,600 PENNSYLVANIA ENUE.
>> WHEN SOMEONE LIKES JAMES MAKM
VIHE TION.RETIREDOUR STA MARIN
WE AREITNESS CONSEQUENCES OF TH
T MATURELEADERSHIP.
THE WHITE HOUSE IGNORED TTIS'IS
NUMBER OF LABR.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS THE GENERAL
DOESN'T CLUE IN WHAT'S
GOONOR WORSE TURNED AYE
IT.
>> Reporter: SOURS SAY MATTIS'
CONDEMON HAVE
COUENCES.
HES WIDELY REVERED BOTIES AND H
DENOUNCING TRUMP.ENALLLEN SAID
HE WAS STUNNED BY TRUMP'SRCH MO
>> WHAT HAPPENS
AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES.THAT IS
LIBERAL REGIMES.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE
STATES
WE TOLERAT.CHAIRMANS OF THE JOI
SE OUT
N'
SILENCENY LONGER.EN THE PRESIDE
PUSHING BACK HIS
HE FREHEID N
SIGNATION.
ORGOT HOW IT
HA OR IS ANS ARE TRYING TOAVOID
SAID.BUY ALASKA SENATOR LISA
MURCOWSKI CA
NECESSARY AND OVE.
SHE STRUGGLING
WHETHER TO SUPPORT THESIDENT
MBER.TRUMPDDAY AS THE FENCES ES
ON WNIGHT.
TH I FRONTTHEE OSAN 8 FOOT FENC
ARRESTED ANDAETF
SO CONTROLLING WASNG
AY S NCS THE'SUSE.
AHOINHIBIAN
DOFF.JAKE,HE TO GO TO HIS NEW
JERSEY GOLF CLUBHI WE
THE WHITE HOUARE CSELLING THAT .
THE PRESIDENT WILL MAI SWAFACTO.
BASICAY,ADVISERSHOUGHT THE
OPTICS O H HIS OWN
GON THE NATION IS
L EXPE T SO MUCH
PROTESTS, ALL THIS RUN U UNREST
ALLEN WHO FAFGHYS SO TO HAVE Y
UNITED STATES INTO ILL
LIBESM M W HAV
ON J 1st, ER
OF THE END OF THE AMERICANPEU M?
>> I'M VERYJAKE SEEIS AMERICANPR
TO TER W CONDUCTES E
AS TERRORISUSTIFY U
MILITARY FORCE. ABOUT THAOR STR
COUNTR ATTACKED TO THA I O IN
JAKE.
WHATUL RIGHT  GNG FROM COV AND I
AF TERRIBLE
RDEO A ERVICETH OUGHT
A HEALING ENVIRONMENT FOR US.WE
THEY ARE, IN RCST
PEACEFULYND FREED OF
SPEECH.  YOU HEARING
FROM PEORENARY  NOTBL SPEAK A Y
>>EA ACMPLISHIN TEX
APX
ER CAN QUICKLY.
ONCEAGAIN, WEUL LESS
TIME TRYING TO LEAD THE CS AGAI
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND MUCH MORE
TIME TRYINGHA
OF LEGISVE RE.E THOSE CONDITIONS
THTEON OF THE
RIGHTSGE ENOUR POPULATION FOR T.
THAT'S W
IN TRYING TO DOTO SIAGRIEES TT .
LET'SHE
CPASSNAETIC ERSHIPBRACE EVERY
CANION T
UNDERTAKEREFORMS TOICE DO THE G
THEIPULATION.L FOLKS GOT TO
BE
THERE MIGHT BEORISTS. CRIMINALS
ABOUT MAKING THE AMERICADO CA WE
THE TUATION THISCOUNTRNT TRUMPD
PROKHE  ACT, WHICH SENDIVE DUTY
INGR A
THE '50s DURING R
1967 ANDK
ND MAYORS H
SUBSNTAWCAPATIAW EVEN FORCEMENT
THE PATR
TES, IF THEY DON'T HAVTY CONTROE
OCONTROL, POTENTIAL
RIOTING, THEEUARD.OK ITAVED  LOD
THEY ARE VERY GOOD TROOPS.
HVERNOR U DEY TO L FO
GOES NEEDORE THAN THAT,
HEY SHOULD ASK
ESWHEN THE PRESIDENT TELLEMIS
STANDARD OF HOW WILLAY DOMINAT
THE  CONSIDER THE CITIESBAFACES
'S FOR ILELYECIS
WOULDMP.>>OU H CONCERNS
UM
LEADERSHIPU OBVIOUSLY ENDORSEDN
FOUR STAR MARINEEN LIKEYOER AS
OF DEFENSE FORTRUMP, FALMA CRIT.
INCH SAID TOUGH
INCLUDING TRUMP ISRE SEEN TOSEES
ICHARECOHAVE YOU TALKED TO HIM?
E COMNGE AND
COME OUT WITH A SINGLEESIS ON T
OFS.IS VIEWS OTH
MATTER.
I F OVER I NEVE
COHRCE HNS
WE S IT TOW
E  ISADMINISTERED T